let's bring in former governor of
arkansas mike huckabee
uh governor good morning to you always
good to see you sunday mornings not the
best of news to start with you today
let's spin it forward if we might you
heard president joe biden there talking
about
giving new resources to police officers
it's a stark contrast what we heard over
the past what's been 18 months where
we've heard his entire party including
joe biden talk about the concept of
defunding the police so i don't know how
much credibility we can give the message
but i don't also know how much
persuasion or sway he ever has over his
party governor
well i don't think he has a whole lot of
sway over his party they're having a lot
of sway over him he was elected because
they said he was a moderate well he's
been anything but
now i don't know who wrote that speech
for him i'm very sure he did not write
it i'm not sure he understood what he
was saying
i'm glad he said it whoever wrote it
ought to be given at least some
commendation for having some common
sense to recognize that we don't need
fewer police and we need to respect the
ones we have if anything instead of
defund we need to defend the police and
i'm glad for that message but let's hope
there's something behind it other than
just the words at a ceremony because
otherwise we're going to keep losing
cops and we're also going to keep losing
our safety and our freedom
you know governor there's so much about
that
whole scene that we saw with joe
president joe biden that i didn't like
starting with the fact that he had his
sunglasses on during that i for some
reason it just i didn't like it
but i also think that the police
officers aren't buying it i mean there's
a reason why the national
fraternal order of police endorsed joe
biden's opponent donald trump um i think
these are people whose jobs i mean it's
life and death they know who has their
back whether it's the border patrol um
or you know the police officer on the
beat here in new york or anywhere across
the country we were talking earlier
governor the only time we really saw
this overflowing love of our law
enforcement from our leaders in the
democrat party including joe biden was
when they could use the capitol police
to advance this message on january 6
that somehow everybody was you know an
insurrectionist and they needed to play
this up that's that's the most love i've
seen other than that it's been you know
defund and and and reinventing or
reimagining law enforcement
rachel let's not forget that it wasn't
that many days ago that joe biden in a
rather unscripted moment of the white
house talked about how he was going to
hold accountable
those border patrol agents who were
simply doing their jobs at the border on
horseback now that was an unscripted
moment that's when it's just joe biden
speaking from his heart or his head
or from wherever he's speaking at that
particular moment but that really was
the true joe biden coming out there
where he basically threw his own agents
under the horse
and that was disgusting
you really got a real good picture of
what he thought about police officers
versus illegal immigrants
illegally crossing the border and trying
to rush against the law enforcement of
our country so let's let's ask the real
joe biden to stand up let him trot out
there in front of the podium at the
white house
and answer unscripted questions
to the reporters who are assembled there
and then we'll find out what he thinks
yeah he's not doing that uh so we won't
hold our breath but it would be
interesting if he actually did you know
you mentioned the radical policies
governor radical policies come from
radical people with radical backgrounds
and this white house has shown a
willingness to continue to advance those
types of people two examples first is i
don't even know how to pronounce the
name sal amarov i believe is proposed to
be the new comptroller of the currency
and then you've got the new pick to lead
up border security as well here's what
sally omarov who would be in charge of
our currency uh said in a tweet in 2019
until i came to the us i couldn't
imagine that things like gender pay gap
still existed in today's world say what
you want about the old ussr the soviet
union but there was no gender pay gap
market doesn't always know best also the
a graduate of moscow university moscow
state moscow state university also wrote
a thesis there about marxism as well
which they're trying to get unsealed but
they haven't been able to react yet and
there's why yeah here's a quote on the
border patrol chief this is an op-ed by
chris magnus said as the police chief
here i'm deeply troubled by the trump
administration's campaign against
sanctuary cities which refused to turn
over undocumented immigrants to federal
authorities the harsh anti-immigrant
rhetoric and mr sessions reckless
policies ignore basic reality so if you
have a control comptroller of the
currency who likes the ussr more and
someone who's supposed to lead the
border patrol effort who believes in
sanctuary policies then what do you
expect
you know we used to have a saying in the
governor's office personnel is policy
what that means is the people you pick
will be the policies that you implement
so when you see people like this and and
in particular
this person nominated for the
comptroller of the currency in other
words they have a major influence on our
economic policies and how we will
approach not only the world banking
community but how will we will approach
our own economy and her excuse for this
is well you're attacking me because i'm
an immigrant i'm a woman and and because
i'm a minority no has nothing to do with
that
even if you were a sixth generation
white american male
if you went to moscow state university
and you talked about the superiority of
the ussr
to the united states in terms of
economic freedom literally right we
would question whether or not you're fit
for that job it has nothing to do with
your ethnicity or your immigration
status has nothing to do with uh your
minority status it's that's insane and
that's a typical liberal response to try
to keep from answering honest questions
about why on earth would joe biden
nominate you i say it again
personnel is policy and what we're
seeing is left-wing uh policy because
he's appointing left-wing people yeah i
remember him on the campaign trail
governor saying do i look like a
socialist do i look like a socialist i
mean it's like but everything he's doing
is is in in that in that direction and
and we're on this fast track and we're
seeing our economy falling apart our
inflation going up empty shells all the
things that you kind of see at the
beginning of a socialist
you know country
you really do get the impression bernie
sanders is president he's just not
getting the secret service detail
doesn't get to sleep at the white house
and have all those cool meals all the
time but despite that he's really
running things in terms of how the
policy of this country is being driven
the irony is bernie's not even a
democrat
he's a
independent but he's an avowed socialist
so
why on earth would we be allowing our
country to be run ideologically by
somebody who essentially
is diametrically opposed to the
fundamental american principles of free
enterprise free enterprise made this
country great it'll keep this country
great we abandon it and we will suddenly
see something different instead of a
long line of people trying to break into
the country we might for the first time
in our history see a line of people
trying to get out but so far
there is no line of people trying to get
out they're still trying to get in how
cool are the meals in a governor's
mansion
i was you mentioned how cool the meals
are for the white house are the
governor's mansion meals cool
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
it's a pretty it's a pretty sweet gig to
be honest with you you know i'll tell
you for for somebody who had to live in
public housing for almost 11 years the
governor's mansion is about as good as
public housing will ever get i imagine
that's true
you know you gave us a couple of truisms
here that personnel is policy which is
something i'm sure i will remember and
there's another one that i've always
held tight to i believe that politics is
downstream from culture so let me give
you a story from the american culture
right now and that is superman dc comics
abandoning the the saying truth justice
in the american way dropping american
way putting in now a better tomorrow
superman stands for truth justice and a
better tomorrow what does this say about
our culture governor where we're headed
well the
real truth is
the american way is a better tomorrow
it's when we abandon the american way
that we don't have a better tomorrow
tomorrow for most people is the
opportunity
to go somewhere
different than where you started
america is about not having to stop
where you started it can be that you
grew up in poverty and one day you can
live in prosperity
one day you can be
without hope and the next day you can be
on top of the world look at the great
accomplishments of people who started
with nothing
you know i kind of named myself among
those uh first male and my entire family
lineage to ever graduate high school
much less go to college
you know where could i have done this
except in america so when i hear people
say let's not talk about the american
way i say no let's talk about the
american way because there's no place on
planet earth where you'll have a better
tomorrow than you'll have if you live by
the grace of god in the united states of
america
so well said so well said governor uh
and one last topic if we could uh will
mention the governor's mansion well it
appears uh your daughter's raised a lot
of money to get a chance to to go where
you once were 11 million dollars she has
raised so far
in the arkansas governor's race if you
would give us an update how's it going
well first of all i'll tell you nobody's
ever raised money like this for any race
ever in the history of the state i've
told people if i could raise money like
this girl i'd be president right now i
mean what a fundraising deal she's got
going but to be honest she's going to
need it because already so much money
from silicon valley in hollywood is
being poured in against her but she's
tough
i think the greatest thing about her
being governor other than the fact she
would be a great leader she has core
values and convictions and she knows who
she is the other thing that would be
great is that when her three children
try to hide
she knows where all the cool hiding
places are because she grew up there so
it would be pretty sweet that's so funny
you say that because i was invited once
to stay and christy gnome at governor
christie gnomes at the governor's
mansion and she showed my kids all the
hiding places so that when we woke up in
the morning actually so that we could
sleep in in the morning and the kids
could all play hide and seek so that's
uh that's interesting those governor
mansions do you have little hiding
places um for kids that's funny you said
that very cool all right i'll tell you
one other thing real quickly just real
quickly
there's cameras everywhere on the ground
so it's not like they really get away
with anything while they're there that's
what i need
that's true all right governor thank you
so much
have a great day